I got this 24 pack of modeling clay for my kids.
It has a bunch of little colors,
and I'm gonna be honest, at first,
I was a little skeptical. It did sit outside in the Florida sun for,
like, almost 24 hours,
and it was in a hot car, so I was kind of afraid that with the bubbles,
this was going to be messed up.
Oh, look,
Mommy's already using it to make a banana,
which is his favorite fruit.
But it is really good quality.
It feels kind of foamy,
so it's not quite like the hard clay that I have seen,
but it's much easier to work with,
according to Madison. It's much easier to work with,
and they are very excited.
There are 24 different colors.
Got a bunch of them right here.
Blueberry and a blueberry.
Look at that. So
if your kids are really creative and love to make things out of clay,
I highly recommend you get this on the TikTok shop.